iraq's stability is key to the stability
of the whole region
this is how regional leaders
participating in the bharadat conference
for cooperation and partnership
concluded it on saturday
the summit which discussed economic
integration and investment projects
between the participants
also addressed political and security
challenges facing iraq
including the possible resurgence of
isil
iraqi officials say it's an opportunity
to ease tension in the middle east
as saudi and iranian officials held
talks on the sidelines of the summit
the fact that we managed to bring rival
countries together on the same table and
initiate dialogue between them is not
only important to them in us but the
whole region
the meeting which was co-organized by
france also addressed the water crisis
the war in yemen
and the devastating economic and
political situation in lebanon
i think it's promising because it's laid
the foundation to involving iraq in more
bilateral meetings with the participant
countries in the future the presence of
france and the international
organizations gives credit to this
summit
international and regional summits have
been held
to discuss instability in iraq for
decades
now it's hosting this one
to show it's ready to regain a rule in
the region
and says it will be neutral in ongoing
conflicts
back in june iraq held a trilateral
summit to establish trade integration
and development to projects with egypt
and jordan
saturday's summit is another step in
sending a message of arab solidarity
with iraq
after years of isolation
mahmoud al jazeera
bernard